actualizamos la información económica
con Daniela Blandón Daniela saludo para
usted Hola Ángela vamos a hablar de
Estados Unidos el plan de que el
presidente
del día de hoy su plan de presupuesto y
con sus salsas de impuestos Sí señora lo
va a presentar en el estado pendular de
Pensilvania dará a conocer entonces este
proyecto que está repleto de gastos
también de impuestos más altos para los
ricos que servirá como preámbulo para su
esperada y no confirmada a un
candidatura a la reelección en 2024 se
han ido conociendo detalles
extraoficialmente como por ejemplo que
incluiría un impuesto mínimo del 25% a
los hogares que tengan fortunas
superiores a los 100 millones de dólares
así como una alza del impuesto
corporativo del 21 al 28%. el objetivo
final es reducir el déficit
presupuestario en alrededor de tres
billones de dólares en una década la
Casa Blanca explicó este último punto
eso es una diferencia de Casi 6 billones
de dólares entre el presupuesto del
presidente y la agenda de los
republicanos en el congreso que
agregaría tres billones de dólares a la
deuda el presidente biden asumió el
cargo después de que su predecesor
firmara para beneficiar a las
corporaciones grandes y ricas con
declaraciones de impuestos imprudentes y
no pagadas lo que agregó casi dos
billones de dólares al déficit Angela
sobre eso hay que decir que si el año
pasado le fue imposible a biden pasar
estas propuestas cuando tenía más peso
en la cámara de representantes este año
será mucho más difícil ahora que son los
republicanos los que la controlan y que
estamos en pre carrera electoral Daniela
el presidente chileno por otro lado
tampoco está contento condenó el rechazo
del legislativo de su reforma tributaria
Claro que sí apenas a un año de haber
llegado al poder Gabriel borich buscaba
crear el primer impuesto sobre la
riqueza del país pero su propuesta
incluida dentro de una ambiciosa reforma
fiscal no alcanzó los votos necesarios
para su aprobación en la cámara de
diputados y tendrá que un año si quiere
volver a radicarla en esta misma cámara
este texto eliminaba algunas extensiones
Fiscales elevaba el impuesto sobre la
renta para quienes ganen más de 5.300
dólares al mes también establecía
incentivos a la inversión y nuevos
mecanismos para penalizar la evasión
fiscal después de este rechazo en la
cámara el presidente reaccionó de
inmediato en redes sociales dijo que
está perjudicó a millones de chilenos y
chilenas que han luchado por pensiones
dignas por mejor distribución de la
riqueza entre otros los detractores de
la propuesta en cambio dicen que lo que
haría sería provocar una fuga de
capitales
el mayor banco de Estados Unidos Daniela
demandó a uno de sus ejecutivos una caso
en el que busca trasladar
responsabilidades si la historia es la
siguiente JP Morgan Chase demandó a su
ex jefe de banca de inversión Él es
stalie quien fue luego del banco
londinense barc alegó alega este mayor
banco de Estados Unidos que esta persona
ayudó a ocultar el tráfico sexual eh
abuso sexual de Jeffrey epstein durante
años todo para mantener a este
financista como uno de sus mejores
clientes ese banco afronta hoy Dos
procesos uno del gobierno de Islas
Vírgenes
estadounidenses y uno de una mujer que
dice haber sido abusada por epsin ambos
lo señalan de haberse beneficiado de
este cliente como
uno de sus de sus usuarios a sabiendas
de su comportamiento lo que busca JP
Morgan es responsabilizarlo a él
personalmente a celi por cualquier
castigo que le vayan a imponer Pues dice
que fue él quien siempre estuvo al tanto
y nunca
recordemos que epstein purgaba en 2019
una condena por pagar a niñas menores de
edad por masajes y luego abusar de ellas
pues ese mismo año él se suicidó vamos
con Los indicadores una creciente
ansiedad por las declaraciones de esta
semana del presidente de la Powell sobre
tasas de interés tiene a las bolsas
europeas en rojo también a los contratos
a futuro Wall Street previo a la
apertura de hoy en Asia las bolsas
cerraron al alza alentadas por el dato
de inflación de China que en enero había
sido del 2,1% interanual y en febrero se
desaceleró al 1% y mi dato empresarial
de hoy es que comparece este jueves el
ceo interino del gigante de cafeterías
Starbucks en Estados Unidos El Congreso
lo pondrá en el banquillo por sus
presuntas malas prácticas de la empresa
en general malas prácticas laborales que
incluyen obstáculos que al parecer
habría impuesto para la creación de un
sindicato en Nueva York y finalmente la
cifra del día 18,9 liras este es el
nuevo máximo histórico del dólar frente
a la moneda turca alcanzado hoy a medida
que los inversionistas sopesan ese
impacto de los terremotos ocurridos hace
un mes el gobierno aprobó un impuesto
extraordinario a unas 22.000 empresas
para contribuir a costear estos 84 mil
millones de dólares que se estima
causaron los terremotos Daniela gracias
a usted y nos vemos mañana Así es Ángela